you have to you have to observe better
so we're going to start going from Aon
to morea application okay
so right and we have sh n coming
out we're going to take the Escape okay
so this one out here then step into the
two on
one I clear the line
Ashley
okay he's going that
way ke's going this
way
angle
deflection One Way angle deviation the
other
way okay let's go okay so you you need
that uh Yin space right it could be he
pulls that's going to be energy okay um
so he pulls and you have uh cou hole
see but we're going to do it from the
arm he's pulling and I'm going to come
in and use the arm to do the top Topsy
turby effect so
this in the same way conceptually if you
can't enter that far you can just pick
up the leg pick up the leg with the
knee sweep the leg this
way but keep this arm
going and look for the
in so as he's going maybe it's a lull
maybe he stopped he stopped okay and
that's going to be but look at his base
that's going to be where I use it okay
let's
TR the other way you can generate a yid
movement is let's say he's going y you
see so I'm just going to move out of the
way he goes Y and nice
shave okay so I'm here maybe he pulled
right now he's going young and I
shape I'll ditch that arm up so we'll be
here the
camera stay here here's where we are
okay as he starts to push on me I shave
this
way so imagine our body is here he goes
to push I move out of the
way I let go of the arm as he pushes and
I take that
head oh here he
[Music]
pushes okay to non contest right when
we're here again just the admin starting
position when he pulls I just moving
with
it but our ego instinct is when he pulls
I brace and then I'll try to go okay so
I'm stuck to him he goes to pull and I'm
moving in with
that he goes to pull and I'm moving in
with
that you should feel it before anyone
else could see it because he's going to
tense his muscles and you're already
moving you're already moving
watch your
instinct and then you
go so it's when he
[Music]
goes it's when he
goes he's basically taking me into the
technique all right let's try
okay another obvious one for the push he
goes to push is just your 10
P you give me 10 P okay and so here you
can you can he he goes to push you can
see you have ju nothing but we're going
to do it from the two on
one again as he pushes don't
brace you should feel it he goes to push
and that's your
Technique okay let's
get he comes around his circles going
that way you see so let's put it on the
clock so you can
see so he's going
clockwise and we usually go inside this
circle going the other way
okay so all all of your
ratio techniques are are like that the
ones that coming in okay so we're going
to use that technique
so I go to the two onone look how I
drive that gets most people to push
that's when I yield he gets his balance
he's going to come in you see well
that's that same Circle he's going
around me I'm going to come inside his
Circle
balance inside his
Circle I don't care if you hold the arm
right now just work the
pattern right
there there's obviously the same timing
so if he pushes and I go like that this
technique doesn't work it's when he
pushes that's when this works same way
as when he pulls that's when all those
work it's not he pulls resist and then
go so the same thing here he pushes a
yield when he goes to stand up that's
when I go can't be standing then I go we
we're
changing
places
okay let's
go here's the elbow arm that's the one I
don't want go up okay so I'll hold the
wrist arm as long as I need to to get
over here you can still hold it if you
want you can still hold it but you don't
need it you can also come to the legs
here on the on the
front right you do want to go around
that Noble arm and the way you get
around it is with that same
softness this
way okay let's go so uh let's
say uh I got a key or he's like trying
to rip my badge off of
me you get get it so same same thing so
he he goes to grab look you're in the
same thing goes to grab boom you're in
the same he goes he does get a grip
doing the same thing he's got a clinch
you see starting to clinch and and
you're in the same exact thing you guys
see that you go right to the two on one
okay so uh you can do it on a grab
attemp you could do it on the ground
just
push you could do it on the clinch
attemp boom and then start any of those
techniques that we went over okay all
right let's
[Music]
go
I so you have to go you do have to go
through a phase where you got to learn
the moves you got to learn the move and
then I I think it's okay to go through a
phase where you kind of slowing the
technique down through
contestation you know just a little bit
and then you do some
yield that's okay that's like a growing
phase as long as you keep training and
again we all know what that means right
four to 6 hours a day listen to your
teacher do all the other mental
trainings you'll get through that phase
but if you're pushing pushing pushing
forcing forcing forc that's a different
phase do do you understand so I I'll
describe it you guys are some of you are
looking at me right here okay so maybe I
go to push and he pushes that is that's
a contestation do you see I don't want
to hold it here and try to shove them do
that one maybe my instinct I pulse on
the resistance and then you'll see me
yield
do you understand that phase is okay got
it so it's okay but he's doing whatever
and I'm very soft very soft okay and I
would like for you to try to lose that
little pulse okay so he does
whatever
I could have feel the Instinct I feel it
in my body and I'm going to release that
like corpse
pose corpse pose look corse pose keep
releasing releasing corse
pose and I would rather do that over the
movement over the
movement
[Music]
always a movement release get out of the
way tail